foreign
so there's been an uptick obviously in
car thefts and specifically in Chicago
okay don't worry the mayor of Chicago is
suing the car manufacturers wait what my
car was stolen um CBS from the Humboldt
Park area uh WGN it was at the end of
June it's a CBS affiliate I think oh no
okay
Sunday August 6th whoa I left my house
to go pick up hold on let me pull the
video I'm sorry guys
let's try this again my car was stolen
um from the Humboldt Park area
um it was at the end of June on Sunday
August 6th I left my house to go pick up
groceries and found it was gone wow
my vehicle was stolen uh in Chicago
Sunday these Kia owners are the latest
victims in a very long and growing list
of individuals who've had their car
stolen across Chicago that's why the
city of Chicago is suing automakers Kia
and so whoever's running this at WGN
you have the audio of the voiceover
coming in on one ear but then the every
all the other audio is coming through
both Hyundai it's only fair that these
companies be held accountable for uh
their failure to include just a very
basic safety features
that's not how it works Dude Perfect the
people that are stealing cars are the
problem
attorney Steve Kane says the two
companies have allegedly deceived
customers into thinking the vehicles
possess anti-theft technology
last summer once videos on social media
were posted showing the security defects
then why aren't you suing Tick Tock for
posting the videos
to the point where in some months uh
more than 60 of all the car thefts in
the city are of Hyundai's and Kias hey
cousin Larry why don't you sue all the
black kids stealing the cars Jesus
Christ what is this I mean
Kane says the stolen vehicles have been
used to commit other violent crimes
oh yeah that's what what about the
criminals it's the car
that include robbery uh and murder so
it's not just the jewelry riding so
we're going to be charging uh Kia and
Hyundai with murder
bad energy trying to get the clearance
rate up they're like we could just if we
can make the charges stick we could get
like half our murders off the books and
just charge a charge Kia oh Kelly says
her zeltos was totaled when police
founded days after she reported it
stolen she shared this surveillance
video to show the moments after she says
a group of boys drove off with let's not
point out that she had the park next to
a homeless encampment that's the problem
is that she drove a Kia yeah the promise
you drove a Kia a disaster on so many
levels man they took my car they flashed
their brights the other kid that was
like waiting nearby
he um rides his Divi bike up up dumped
the Divi bike and then jumps in the car
and they take off they run a stop sign
they're speeding Amanda has been a loyal
Kia customer
yeah at a crispy Kreme customer from the
looks of it
holy [__] Amanda yeah we know you're a
loyal Kia oh man you look like one
or since 2007 her 2016 Sorrento was
stolen in Brighton Park early this month
but says when police recovered it this
past Sunday it was damaged this is
insane right imagine this is insane
first if a car manufacturer wanted to it
could make cars without locks it's every
ride and it's your right to [__] buy
it you know I mean cars used to be even
easier to steal than that they were now
now she yeah I I will say that uh it's
we've reached a sad day in history when
a car like a Kia or a Hyundai which had
natural anti-theft protection and that
they were Kias and Hyundai's you know
like your city's so bad [__]
are stealing Kias now
must have good suspension
no if she'll drive it once it gets fixed
is it gonna kick you know keep getting
broken into when will this die down you
are ma'am you are really big
you are so fat that it's making your
hairline recede I'm like what is their
you know
and they're just kind of when you call
they're just kind of like yeah we're not
you know they just kind of brush it off
you bought one of the cheapest cars in
the market that's the other problem so
when you get a cheap car You're Gonna
Get You Know cheap stuff lives in the
suburbs but was near the Garfield Park
Observatory oh Garfield
last weekend for a cultural event when
her 2016 Optima was stolen it's still
missing they stole my horse
[Laughter]
runs with unleaded
before the crime happened she got the
anti-theft software but she says it
proved to be ineffective yes it's not
anti-theft software it's not a guarantee
that your car is not going to get stolen
yeah they're stealing I found out today
they're stealing Audis in Mercedes now
super easily because you could download
for your iPad from different sites an
app and put you in just clone keys and
just steal a car
it was only an upgrade in the computer
system
and obviously
you know then they steal my car again
all they used was a flipper zero this is
this isn't Delirious work a Hyundai
spokesperson right somebody else said
flipper in the chat yeah stating that
they are assisting effectively I learned
that one from Virgin and I looked it up
I'm like I want to buy one of these
we're saying and park quote
bro across the country are maximizing
the number of anti-theft software
installations that can be performed on a
daily basis contributing to steadily
increasing completion rate I want to
know at the Kia anti-theft update was
it made the alarm sound for five minutes
instead of like a minute you know the
update should be there should be a
speaker that says are you sure you want
this it's a Kia are you sure you want
this it's a Kia I mean we're aren't the
kids are the ones that were like getting
stolen with like a USB and the Hyundai's
both of them
Kia also addressing the issue saying in
part quote Kia has been and
could be willing to work cooperatively
with law enforcement agencies in Chicago
to combat car theft
but
the
not long ago and this is even when we
were kids merch there were certain
neighborhoods that you could go to and
not even lock your car and everything
would be in there in the morning and
nobody would steal anything dude I I try
to steal anything he's stealing I uh I
had a panic attack today when I was on
the way here because I was dude I had to
look around at a cumia moment where I
was just running around going where the
[__] is my gut like I was panicking and
it was because if I keep my bag wherever
and it just I was looking at my car and
I was having one he told God I break it
turns on it was on your back it was it
was like next to me in my studio it was
like off to the side on the floor I was
like oh God thank God my wallet was in
it my gun was in like everything was in
it and I'm like please tell me I didn't
leave it in my car and I did I thought
it was bizarre because I don't leave
[__] in my car because even my girl I
have a I live in an okay town with an
okay car they'll steal my [__] and the
role social media has played encouraging
it and we remain committed to supporting
our customers into vehicle security I
would have also the cars from 2016 all
your warranty these are over anyway both
of these cars from 2016. recommended key
in a heartbeat and now what why it's a
Kia I mean you mean recommend it to
other poor people right right exactly
I would say run as fast as you can I
would ma'am I would recommend a
heartbeat
man I would recommend keto to you in a
heartbeat okay that's what I would
recommend to you or whatever heartbeats
you have left yeah I was gonna say I
don't think she knows what a heartbeat
is you [__] Mammoth just one heavy
pump every top of the hour
just working down the turkey one beat
per minute one beat per hour
Kia or Hyundai she doesn't have a
resting heart rate she has a comatose
heart rate it's pretty much she has
people what their BPH is and they're
like what
beats per hour
now Kane hopes the lawsuit will provide
some Financial relief for the city and
Carl for the city that's what it is it's
the city's fault you're shaking down the
city's fault that you can have a
question how come this [__] ain't
happening in other places
how come it's not happening in other
places and also can we pretend like this
payoff wouldn't like you wouldn't
immediately still be bankrupt
this is so [__] stupid the car
manufacturer you paid for the car you
know what you got it why aren't you
suing Tick Tock for showing how to
[__] break into these cars oh because
it's uh tick tocks owned by China and so
is Chicago we'll get a break here one
second I think this is our challenge is
a relatively new and illegal Trend
circulating on social media it involves
thieves targeting Kia and Hyundai
Vehicles you got to think he is like why
don't they call the [__] Hyundai
challenge why do they got to call the
[__] Kia challenge I gotta say I
really enjoy the fact that every every
now now they're just Tick Tock just has
this new trend where we just name a
crime and then put the word challenge
after it like the Team Takeover flash
mob challenge Street takeover challenge
hey guys the keep the challenge my name
is Tyler I'm doing the rape a hobo
challenge hey what's up man my name is
Dave and I'm on Tick Tock to tell you
all about the new uh share child
pornography challenge she's like what
well you're on tick tock
you're like yeah this is pretty
redundant bro hey these Fort Sanders has
more from those who've become the
targets of these crimes and what car
experts are saying it's another day of
work at tech one auto in North Austin
cars better than Tech N9 Auto which is a
bunch of white people saying to listen
to Black music because they listen to
Tech Nine yeah just like this Hyundai
are waiting to be serviced however it's
not for normal maintenance we see him at
least once twice Jesus Christ that guy's
voice you know what that's a cool voice
you got to give it that's a cool voice
you sound like you should be voicing an
animated Bear yes in a [__] Pixar
movie right
so it is becoming a major problem Andrew
West a service advisor at tech one auto
says it's stemming from a social media
Trend called the being black be a
challenge thieves are breaking into the
steering column and starting up certain
Kia and Hyundai models in a matter of
minutes like they used to do back in the
day back in the day stealing cars was
super easy touch two wires yeah that was
it without an immobilizer anything have
you tried using the club
is the club making a big company yeah we
should get the club back get the club
that resembles a key can be used to
start the vehicle k-view viewer Ray
Johnson sent me this video of one of
these cars being dumped in front of
their home in Del Valley police told
them it was stolen out of Hayes County
cars just like this Kia are pretty
popular here in America
you see them keep looking here
oh my God dead my kid my kid he just
runs over a baby stroller that
popularity is also making them a Target
when it comes to this illegal Trend
that's going by the way kids aren't
popular America is poor and by the way
Kias aren't even cheap like they used I
mean relative to other cars there are
but they're still expensive now
everything's expensive now social media
thieves are taking cables just like this
iPhone cord and they're actually
breaking into the car's steering column
jamming the USB side into parts that
make the car actually stop so you're
telling people how to do it yeah even
though they just censored it on the
thing art allowing them to pull off in a
matter of minutes here's how you steal
the Kia hey give me your Kia it's fine
it's okay yeah you can have it here you
go I'll get insurance I'll get a Honda
that's exactly what South Austin
resident Nick stroll went through I had
a Hyundai it was a 2021 Hyundai Tucson
whoa millionaire money money bags money
bags McGee you know what I like to break
sometimes too but you know maybe show
some humans
oh my God Clorox shallow shot boys it's
actually considered it uh in Buffalo a
local Kia dealership plans to give
owners the club to ward off car thieves
Nick parked his car at his apartment
complex after work just like any other
night however when he went to use it the
next morning wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute you're driving around in a 2021
Hyundai and you live in an apartment
something that doesn't add up are you he
must like to just live a Spartan
lifestyle right yeah yeah that's what it
is that's what it is nowhere to be found
and I was like maybe it's somewhere else
I walk on the whole complex for like 25
minutes and I'm like my car is nowhere
to be found after a week of the police
working to find Nick's car he got they
didn't no call they're like you know you
know hey we just found your car it
didn't have any plates on it it's
totally damaged I asked him how is it
and they said ah
not great it's a Kia so you might not
notice a difference yeah the whole car
is sideswiped and they ripped the
steering column out there's up to maybe
600 worth of damage to this car
it was in a hit and run collision with
another vehicle everything was there
but it was completely damaged wrecked
Hyundai told me it was 600 in damage so
the car was considered totaled
I used to have one of my first cars uh
when I was young I was like 16 17. I had
one of the old 5.0 Mustangs you know the
fox body once was a badass right okay
except the thing is they stole my car
once when I was at the time working at
Sawgrass mall all they did was stick a
screwdriver and hit it with a hammer and
go like this and it turned on that's all
they did they did nothing else
we're so easy to steal
well terrible it's like someone was just
I had an 89 Camaro it started oh then
you know what I'm talking about you
started with yeah somebody else had
[__] with it before I bought it so I
mean I could bring my keys if I wanted
to but I could just get in my car and
turn the [__] thing with my hand yeah
it was it was just a wild scenario last
summer is when the train began to gain a
lot of traction and Wes says they still
see these issues every single day so
what can be done to deter these
criminals I have an idea have you tried
suing the car manufacturers yeah that's
a brilliant I was thinking what if you
um had the police arrest them
yeah and put them in jail I know hold on
hold on hold on
I have an idea and Mer and we'll go to
break right after this so this this is
actually perfect I have an idea
for a way we could stop them
[Music]
yes I love this
[__] God RoboCop so good
[Music]
you used to be able to get into cars
like that too by the way yeah
[Music]
unironically this by the way
definitely like this idea of the promise
and you're gonna have stinky roasted
human smell in your car yeah that
doesn't come out Hey look it's a dude
from Gremlins final word and all those
clams
no need to trouble he was great and
Scrooged
thank you
okay but then your car would stink
s
yeah it's going to smell better probably
it smells like barbecue
Korean barbecue
so people are specifically stealing Kias
and Hyundais yes so the solution would
be don't buy a Kiara on it no no that's
poor people cars poor people need cars
the all-new Kia Sorrento a work a Sprite
can with 150 horsepower oh my God that's
exactly what that [__] thing is let's
bring back the Hugo and the pinto
forever two wheels she ain't a lady
unless she's 380. uh tomorrow's Mercedes
a cultural event hmm I wonder what kind
of culture Irish serpent I was going to
suggest Kia make their car alarm sound
like smoke alarms then I realized it
would be ineffective that no that would
be effective then the guy doesn't know
the alarm's going off
the thief I mean yeah it's perfect he'll
be driving around with the [__] thing
chirping and everybody'll go wait a
minute
then I'll be like what how did you know